[Music]
did you see this chorizo thing top
scientist admits space telescope image
was actually a slice of chorizo get
[ __ ] owned this is pretty good
proxima centaur centauri the closest
star to the sun located 4.2 light years
from us she was taken by the jwst this
level of detail a new world is revealed
day after day
which is like beautifully written the
whole time it was just a picture of
chorizo dog he just equipped so many
like conspiracy people with the worst
ammo you could see you can't [ __ ]
tell the difference man that guy clowned
you all the piece of chorizo you [ __ ]
sheep i mean that looks like the most
delicious planet i've ever seen i don't
quite get how you believe in science
when you are all worshiping a piece of
chorizo it is a funny commentary on like
the period of time right after nasa you
know posted that new image from whatever
telescope or whatever yeah you know it
was like what was the significance of
that again they re-shot famous images
captured by the hubble and then they
revealed like insane details like
there's like this one that like this
well what's great about this is like
this could have just been made with mid
journey could it just be lying to us oh
yeah no we got higher res images yeah
high res cool star stoner poster you'd
find at a piercing shop and that's what
it would create right there yeah so the
karina nebula previously that like wall
of i don't know what the [ __ ] that is
gas and [ __ ]
that's the perfect summary of the
podcast right there i was saying
previously this wall of gas and [ __ ]
you couldn't see through it you couldn't
see through this [ __ ] so all those stars
behind it oh that's what this is it's
like a star factory so
like stars get made out of this actually
yeah really yes actually okay i didn't
think it was funny like after they
posted this following week it was like
how many people i followed on instagram
that reposted to their stories with no
commentary just like oh my god yo like
check this [ __ ] out i care about this
it's amazing what we can achieve when we
just work together you don't give a [ __ ]
about space no i do while eating that
sushi while eating that exactly yeah yo
james webb [ __ ] lit yeah yeah posting
that yo check this [ __ ] this shit's
happening you should all should check
this out cause i'm smart and if you
don't like think that this if you don't
share it you're not smart you know at
least we're honest about the fact that
we don't know what the [ __ ] it is this
image is dope it's very cool it does
make me feel good looking at it it's
sick for like an album cover or
something yeah well countertop yeah
actually this last yeah yeah it does no
bro this is actually just um a
picture of a of a [ __ ] bowling alley
carpet
before all the pizza and chicken fingers
gets ingrained into it and just ruins it
yeah that's what that [ __ ] is
that's good that's the one that's good
that's really good
i could tell man you didn't do enough
cosmic bowling in your youtube i didn't
i did play a lot of laser tags
no no go back go back go back go back go
back go back look at that
the third one that one that is [ __ ]
great that's exactly what i'm thinking
right there and it's on wave oh you can
buy it let's buy that
we should [ __ ] we should we should
absolutely do it that's so ugly dude i'm
telling you man bowling alley carpet
come on
come on
okay now go back to james webb i'll go
back to fidel castro yeah
okay alexa show me fidel castro i mean i
still see the marble thing i do see the
marble yeah flash on the couch
yeah two lines of coke right there yep
that's all those people in la shared it
yeah yeah does this not look like
[ __ ] yeah uh what's his faces count i
have to take a [ __ ] just looking at this
[Laughter]
[ __ ] my nose is itching now i have to
take his [ __ ] does coke make you want a
[ __ ] not that you would know it makes
you [ __ ] does it yeah it's like a
diuretic or whatever i didn't know that
no no that makes you pee it's a it's
like a laxative that's like coffee like
speeds up your system okay any upper
makes you [ __ ] no that's a nicotine too
that's medical advice here guys
cocaine's like coffee i'm saying like
it's effects on your on your no no no no
no the spread of rumor if you're
constipated it's like pre-workout that
actually is true though
yeah it is actually how much you want to
bet there's something something not
legal in full send pre-workout all of my
money did you see the clip of of uh i
think it was i think it was on uh more
plates more dates or whatever he came up
and i recommend it and it was like kyle
from full send tells elon musk to take
pre-workout right when he wakes up and i
was like what the [ __ ] click and it was
him bit like kyle's like literally like
you ever take pre-workout in the morning
and elon musk is like no he's like no
seriously it's sick you wake up right as
your alarm goes off and you just dump
some in your mouth and then you're so
jittery you're so jittery you have no
choice but to get up and the elan's like
oh i'll have to try that yeah did you
watch any clips from that podcast
for sure you think so yeah no but but
you said that last week and then i was
like wait elon musk does not need money
he's the richest person in the world
that doesn't mean he's not taking it
there's no way
any amount of money that they could have
paid him is not just a drop in the
bucket for him bro why would his most
important thing is probably his time why
would he sit down for an hour
if he didn't see some sort of benefit in
it you know over money i think money was
there to open the door to the
conversation elon's ego is so big you
don't think that dude would take [ __ ]
300 grand to go sit with those dudes for
now no 300 grand he makes that in like a
second literally
yeah
i i think this guy is always about his
hustle i would argue that elon will take
any money this guy probably has multiple
low interest loans of hundreds of
millions of dollars that he doesn't have
to pay taxes on totally i still think
he'd take the money how'd you get his
email well john john we'll tell the
story we'll we'll tell it when elon gets
here but elon for
uh nine years now it's 2013. are you
guys boys we're cool i mean you know she
always takes care of me we run into to
each other sometimes here and there and
first name basis
yeah
that's [ __ ] lit um
what do you mean first what else like he
like does
bro i love him that's how he processes
things so like what's it like like are
you dapping is it just knucks
yeah are you pulling in like is there a
conversation after the dab okay so
maybe they didn't pay him i for sure
would have thought it was like some
weird like hey we're willing to pay this
much to get you on i i don't know it's
crazy that this happened
you